what's going on everybody welcome to
part two of our data visualization apps
with Python and - tutorial series in
this tutorial we're gonna be talking
about is how we can have the user
interact with the actual app itself and
pull that information do something with
it and update the app live in real time
so with that let's just jump into it
we're gonna bring in one more import and
that's gonna be from - dependencies
we're gonna import
input and output now we want to go ahead
and do is pretty much we're gonna redo
the layout I think so we'll keep
children and in fact I probably
well we didn't tab so we'll just delete
this here so we're just gonna redo
what's gonna come you know inside the
children part of the app dot layout but
what we're gonna say is DCCC so that -
core components dot input so - core
components and on fourth I'm not really
sure why I mean in theory I guess it's
an HTML component but this one's a
special like input would generally be an
HTML component but an input in this case
is kind of special because it needs to
have some JavaScript about it because it
needs to be able to grab the information
that's in there and update it so in fact
we're gonna use d c c dot input but just
make sure you're recognizing that that's
input from the - core components that is
not input from - dot dependencies we're
going to be using that input momentarily
so DCC input and then so that's like an
input field that's going to be an input
field and in basically the HTML so it's
gonna have similar similar parameters
that you might have in an input field so
for example we're gonna have an ID
that's going to be we're gonna call that
input and if you're familiar with you
know programming with or writing HTML
let's be serious not a program just piss
some people off it's you have to have an
ID in order to interact with it if you
wanted to populate it or do something to
it or apply some rules to it needs to
have an ID so you basically are going to
have to have an ID there value that
just gonna be the starting value
whatever you want enter something and
then finally the type that that thing is
in this case it's just text so we're
just gonna say text so if we have an
input we might as well have an output
now interestingly enough we you know be
again if you're coming from you know
HTML and stuff like that you know the
output could be anything just it needs
to have an ID of wherever you want to
throw that output to so some Java
scripts gonna run and it's going to
populate something of some ID we just
need to have that something so this
doesn't actually need to be a - core
component it just needs to be an HTML
element that has a certain ID so in that
case it's just HTML div and then the ID
here is going to be output so simple
enough that's all that's our out it's
gonna be our layout so literally it's
just going to be a field that we input
something into and the output will be
the results of whatever it is we happen
to type into there so now what we're
gonna do is actually make a function
that's going to handle the input and
give us whatever the output is you know
produce some output so what we're going
to do now is it's going to be a wrapper
so app dot callback and if you're not
familiar with decorator slash wrappers I
do have a tutorial on them go to either
Python program at net find this tutorial
or you could actually just search
decorators or wrappers on Python program
at net if you want to know more about
how these work exactly so now in the
callback is where we're going to use
that - dot dependencies input and output
so what we're gonna say is the output is
going to be the based from the component
underscore ID of output and then the
component property that we're gonna be
modifying basically it will just be the
children so so this should already if
you're thinking ahead this should
already get you maybe a little excited
because you in theory could could be
modifying more than just the contents
you could modify a lot of properties so
most of the time you're probably just
gonna be modifying children but the
thought that you could I you could
actually modify more than just the the
tenses interesting to say the very least
now we're going to say is the input
we're gonna put that into a list and
that is going to be component ID that
will be input and then we're gonna say
the component property property in this
case is going to be whatever the value
is of that input field we want that to
be the input into this function now
right now this is just a wrapper we
actually need the function that this is
going to wrap so define and and honestly
you can call this whatever you want you
don't have to call this you could just
name it anything at this point but we'll
call it update value it's going to take
input data and then at this point we can
do anything we can return and in this
case it's expecting us to have sorry my
nose is super itchy it's expecting us to
have some text so we'll say input colon
and then we'll just do this format and
it should be a value so just input data
it should already be in string form so
literally it's just gonna output exactly
what we input so let me go ahead and
save that let me run that hopefully we
won't run into server issues let me
start it up bring it down here and so it
says enter something and as we type I
didn't really specify this on the
initial kind of when I was showing you a
few of the apps but it wasn't like I was
typing a ticker and then hitting Enter I
was just typing the ticker and it just
automatically updated so as you can see
just updates in real time now there's
obviously this is a super simple example
of you know what you could do but you
could immediately start to to throw in
other things so for example we could say
try that except actually I'm not even
gonna do an exceptional let's just
return
some error that hurts so what we could
say is instead let's say return the
string value of float input data times
two
actually let's do ^ 2
and I should work save it let's see if
we hit err
nope so oh shoot I went too far let's
see here we go
let's refresh so some error of course
because that's not a number 1 ^ 2 - we
can do 4 5 - 55 and so on and so anyways
that's some starting basic logic but I
think what we'll do is I'd like to show
that app that uh that just graphs some
stock information if you don't know
anything about financier stocks that's
okay people are always like I don't know
anything about finance whenever I show
stuff with finance that's like super
basic
it's just dates and values just if you
don't know anything about finance just
ignore the fact that it's finance so and
if you want to use something else like
pull some data from cuándo pull your own
data it doesn't really matter to me but
I'm just going to show a quick example
of you know rather than just taking
input and output what if we dynamically
graphed based on some input dynamically
graphs on some stock that has that exact
symbol I think that will kind of even
further drive this point home and show
all the things that we can kind of
modify in a function like this so
anyways that's we're going to be doing
the next tutorial if you have questions
comments concerns whatever feel free to
leave them below otherwise I'll see you
in the next tutorial